your biggest fan is peeking around the
corner over there but it's your husband
I think the same thing is getting to you
and she just said Jared she just said Oh
Jared you can't say anything used to so
Jared I walked into this room and within
I was like can we please get a
microphone mister goodbye honey welcome
to CBS this morning your first interview
on CBS s pointy Jerry tell us about the
walk on the mall last night with your
wife
great company a beautiful scenery well
there we couldn't quite convince
President Trump senior advisor and
son-in-law to join us at the table major
is trying yeah he did that was when we
were at the White House on Monday Jared
Kushner doesn't usually talk to the
press but he did speak to the New York
Times along with his wife for a profile
headlined Ivanka Trump has the
president's ear
here's her agenda one of the writers is
New York Times correspondent and CBS
News contributor Jody canter she's here
with new insight into Ivanka's role in
the White House Jody good morning good
morning there's so much good reporting
in here thank you
what is Ivanka doing that we didn't know
about before well that's really why we
were at the story we wanted to probe
that question to me the takeaway of we
had two interviews with her last week
one of them was in the West Wing and to
me the headline was that she is looking
at executive orders before the president
signs them that's a really startling
fact this is somebody who has really no
record of public service no government
experience no Washington experience
she's there because she's the
president's daughter but the same could
be said about the President Washington
experience no government experience
exactly it speaks volumes about this
administration now the other big thing
is that she has really decided that she
wants to focus on gender issues as her
role in this administration she is
saying she wants to pass paid family
leave by the way for men as well as
women that she wants to work on making
childcare more affordable that she wants
to raise money for female entrepreneurs
around the globe this is a really
interesting assignment with some big
questions right she is stepping into a
very difficult and in some ways angry
moment in gender politics Hillary
Clinton has just lost the election in
the interview she was kind of using
language that we appropriate with
Hillary Clinton it was very surprising
in some ways coming out of Ivanka
Trump's mouth and
I don't understand what that means when
she was saying things like we're gonna
unleash the power of women and girls in
the economy that's language we've heard
from Hillary Clinton a real for a really
long time
so the question to me about that is she
trying to kind of atone for or make up
for the problems with her father's
record on women he helped out of that
language though Jody I don't think
that's specific to Hillary Clinton not
specific to Hillary Clinton but given
that she is one of the issue one of the
highest-ranking senior people in this
White House is the president's daughter
and this is the president who really has
trouble has had some trouble with his
record in this area so is she is she
attempting to change that and will she
be able to is there one example where
she has changed her father's mind so far
weight was going this direction and
because of her lobbying for another idea
she went in this direction so she has
weighed in on a number of issues
everything from refugees to climate to
women's health to immigration these are
really broad areas she doesn't see sort
of restrictions to her portfolio and so
the question we wanted to ask is just
how deep is this impact and what she
said is that what she will often try to
do is just sand a decision down around
the edges often she wants to reverse it
and she says she is really trying but
what she says is even if I can make a
small difference even if I can kind of
blunt some of the impact here that's
significant I get this in she's never
publicly going to go up against her
father even when she disagrees with him
she feels that she can work she can walk
right in the Oval Office and speak to
him at any time that is the question and
that's what we talked to Jared Kushner
about when we were on the phone with him
I asked him I really asked him about the
relationship between father and daughter
and how it played out in the Oval Office
and he said their time in there together
is alone they go into the room they
closed the door they're discussing among
themselves and nobody else really knows
what they're talking about now what we
did hear from many sources close to the
Trump's is that Ivanka has an ability to
do something that very few people can do
with Donald Trump which is bring
criticism to him in a
we that he will accept question all turn
asses who can say no to Donald Trump is
she the person who can say no to the
president well he's the president you
know the opening anecdote in our story
is about her pleading with him not
pleading exactly making what we would
call an emphatic case to apologize for
the his comments that were recorded on
the Access Hollywood tape this is right
in the moments after the Reba tape airs
and you know he's very grudging in
responds first he doesn't think it's him
and then he says well you know I
apologize if anybody was offended and
she says to him you know we don't have
her exact words but we talked to several
people who were in the room who said it
you know you this needs to be a really
clear and full apology and it's not
clear that he really listened to her in
the moment he was kind of unyielding and
if you look at that apology later it's
still a little grudging based on your
reporting Jared and Ivanka they're
sometimes called Jovanka together are
they the most powerful advisers inside
the White House well they're family I
think you know I would phrase the
question differently I would say who are
they accountable for because when your
regular White House staff even if you're
incredibly seasoned inexperienced you
can get fired or sort of politely
dismissed and you move on to something
else exciting in your career if you
don't do well and I would say who are
Jared and Ivanka accountable for it is
the president really going to fire his
own daughter and son-in-law it doesn't
seem so well they're accountable to the
laws of the United States government
certainly um but but what is the measure
by which we will we will measure their
work in the White House well it's just
it's really a very compass it's a very
comprehensive gonna give it more space
thank you Judy campaign with you have
you here at the table